[Music]
welcome back to dirty already
the show where we make arthur morgan the
biggest pos
easter egg ever created hi how are you
it's been a while since you said that
you know what it was it was actually uh
it was it was pretty much second nature
jake we've done this for
a while and we're revisiting this game
so
this is the return
and final episode of dirty arty
it is rob hanlery's last week at
gamespot
and we wanted to go out with a bang
and that meant bringing back dirtyarty
for one final
ride that's right and and
you know uh this is one of the biggest
highlights
if not the highlight i i would say in my
time uh seven years at gamespot and i
not gonna lie i i only go back to laugh
because uh god it's just so
fun it was such a fun run
yeah dude this game is so good i was
like
so the whole thing was like i went back
just to reminisce of like some stuff
and namely this show because
man there's nothing really like it and i
think that's why it's so
amazing is just the reactions of
npcs the environment the beauty
there's just so much fun to be had here
it's like its own
gosh darn lifestyle
ecosystem it's so it's such a living
breathing world i'm talking too much
what in holy hell you can't bring that
in here
this guy dude being behind them bars had
you rethinking things
[Music]
one more time
jake what's our goal of this episode we
are going to find the final resting
place for dirty arty
so we are going to start from one end of
the map and travel to the other side of
the map
now we do have mods installed we might
mess with them a little bit but we want
to try to
stay in arthur morgan's shoes
dirty artie's shoes but anyway should we
do that thing that we said we were going
to do for the longest time but never did
it
that's the nature of the show and the
nature of the game
yeah let's do it i just always wanted to
see if there was a reaction here
i'm all in i'll raise you one book
oh i can't drop it
oh that's good enough he left
i'm not here that's enough poker i'm
[Music]
back
did you see that
i live in front of the saloon
next to the freight station you know if
i'm
heading in the right direction oh we're
gonna mislead for sure
just head over that way you'll be home
in no time
well thank you mister am i
glad i asked i got myself
riley spun around
[Music]
there it is
now we gotta go
[Music]
we'll start we'll start way up the
middle of god damn nowhere
so watch this
oh teleport to waypoint baby this
trainer
uh this trainer mod has improved
so much since we did our first module
it looks legit it oh god
that's so legit
uh i didn't ask for this
this was supposed to be legit all right
we're gonna we're gonna do one more mod
here
all right we're in business let's go
boys
there he is we got him back got him back
can you adjust the size of him
why it looks like you're kind of
hovering i made him smaller
oh okay because hey thank you because
the
the one the one that we found was like a
younger one i think because it was
smaller
and just like a standard one is bigger
and it's not as funny
so just riding through a blizzard on a
donkey trying to find his way
it's cool this is the donkey's natural
habitat
it's the snow it's completely equipped
actually this looks a little bit better
for
man that's a lot of bounce on your junk
i
i'm not gonna lie that that makes me
quiver a bit
but dude uh this trainer is
absolutely incredible holy sh
it has improved uh it's improved a lot i
i was having fun messing around with it
it doesn't at least i haven't figured
out a way to make my beard level 10. i'm
sure there's a way
people in the comments be like oh you
could have just done this and i
apologize
but oh yeah you'll you're gonna get so
much hate mail
probably this this doggy needs to chill
out
god i forgot how loud the donkey is
just the noises it makes stop
complaining
i like to imagine like a human in the
booth like
all right do your donkey noises
damn it's a talker holy good lord
all right you know what let's uh
let's see if we can get a quieter one
when i first saw this hologram
i thought i thought you're going to
introduce
a very large donkey donkey but
yeah this is yeah see this one's bigger
that's why i like
oh my god this thing's louder
what is your problem this is dirty
arty's personal hell riding across the
country with a loud the loudest animal
in the world
what that was the donkey yeah like a
person
why
oh here we go
hello
[Music]
feels good to be back oh hello
these guys are so calmly walking out
here yeah i got i got somewhere to go
today
uh yep
it's not gonna turn my back everything's
fine
everything's fine
those sound effects man yep
what are you doing sir
oh well there goes my
all right let me flip
[Music]
oh damn this is heads you gotta kill
this guy man
a good night
easy
imagine taking this donkey on a stealth
mission
hey dirty arnie uh we got an issue you
know we all got horses
i don't i don't think we could do this
mission with your horse
or donkey
[Music]
oh wow stop complaining
easy
here eat an apple
there's a sugar cane or something
spanish and a sugar
now don't kick me off again or i'll blow
you up
[Music]
take the donkey take the donkey boy
put your dogs on leeches
oh
damn it what did he say ain't nothing
dumb
ain't nothing dumber than a wolf pack
all right wow you know i'm not gonna lie
a bit impressed here normally donkeys
seem to disappear
okay
all right he's getting away wow
he just turns around and runs
[Laughter]
too late dude can you get on it
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
look at his legs look at his
legs
oh
get out of my way get a donkey
[Laughter]
yep there we go just swing
up that animation for as broken as it
like
could have been looks pretty great he
kind of swings right up
but holy god those legs do not look
right
yeah get some cinnamon again dude
[Laughter]
i'd advise you to keep quiet hey
no need to
know how to run a good business be tough
be smart
and be fair
domestic supplies and if you're after
the post office well it's over there
fella's an idiot don't judge me for it
catalog right here with my full stop
this guy talks a lot yeah
i think he's really trying to stall what
he knows
appreciate it can i get
every single can of beans you got you
want another one
yeah one another just keep giving your
beans
oh six dozen more thank you very much
sir we don't have any more beans
we'll ping you when it comes
i heard thomas downs passed away poor
fella
you put that gun away right now
damn it oh my god
we gotta get to do a quick getaway for a
second i thought he said damn it
after getting shot in the head yeah get
on
there it is all right what wins
what's your money on oh ah
the train
there was did you see it
oh
[ __ ]
welcome to jurassic park
[Music]
this is terrifying
oh my god is this where i think it is i
think it is
anything you just sleep on the job
margaret
he's back again he's punching all the
cows margaret
[Laughter]
sleeping on the job
you don't know who we are oh you shut
the bottle
oh what
like oh you're so close to dying
dude eat the beans
eat the beans such impressive bullet
time when you're on fire
that full-on concentration
ow whoa that was a guttural
there it is that was incredible
thanks to the donkey
on man cut the ropes off
oh got ourselves a survivor
i think oh oh
oh oh oh you know what to do no no
no no no dude you got bring them with us
get ourselves a traveler it's easy
it's already packaged it's already
packaged for us
well hello what do we have here
i seen mushrooms with bigger brains hey
you ain't no better than me you're more
personality too
let me be you hear me but they didn't
smell as bad
okay i'm gonna leave your goddamn food
keep your distance you here
oh i sprint
okay
good oh hilarious
dirty as hell i'll see you again
hell my friend the classic line
oh my god
look at that dramatic lighting no [ __ ]
this is oscar worthy right here look at
that
how can we before outlaw becomes a piano
man
best picture best actor this is an
oscar worthy landslide
[Music]
i think i should take my career into the
big city
[Music]
stop just stop
and just what have i done to offend you
girl please i'm asking wow you need to
be so close
listen i'm going to leave
this is deaf silence right now i love it
everyone's
looking all eyes on you dirty arty what
you got
[Music]
[Laughter]
i see
[Music]
he just rolled into this bar covered in
[ __ ] and just like
all right
it's pretty good you've heard of the
slow walk away from explosions
but have you ever seen this slow walk
away
gigantic alligators
[Laughter]
oh try to get a drink
yeah that's good enough this is my bar
now
disturb yourself
a little too close to comfort let me
let me head to the other bar maybe
okay this is still out and about
no problem there's no problem
oh [ __ ] that reveal is amazing
that's it here we are this is it
dirty artie's final goodbye it's been a
hell of a run
this is this is definitely been one of
my favorite projects at gamespot
it was fun to give it one last hurrah
yeah i i i'm right there with you and
all i did was laugh
for the most part uh actually except for
that one time where i
spent four hours trying to get all those
cans and that
that uh valentine hotel but regardless
yeah dude
it's been so fun and uh thank you so
much uh
love you dude and love you guys all so
much yeah for
watching like this this [ __ ] would have
yeah put that wick up for one second
you know we we figured a couple episodes
and then it became something else and
there's the uh
there's the night uh but like yeah the
support and the
and the art and all the uh all the
fans and that [ __ ] moon is flying oh
i think i broke something whatever
better send it off then
thank you all so much we'll see y'all on
the flip side
oh it didn't kill him hold on do one
more
that didn't hurt i barely felt the thing
give me a second
[Music]
it's been a long day
without you my friend
and i'll tell you all about it when i
see you
again it's become a long
way from where we began
oh i'll tell you all about it when i
see you again when i see you
again
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]